so what do you do here at khan academy
uh so i'm a
software developer i mostly work on the
front end part of our website
um and over the years i was an intern
twice and i've worked on
things like
building and designing exercises that we
use on our site i've worked on tools
that our content creators use to make
exercises on our site
i've worked on some of our
internationalization efforts i helped
get some of our exercises to be
translatable
i'm currently working on making some of
our images more translatable
i've worked on some of our open source
projects i helped create contact which
was helped
type setting library for the web that's
actually an interesting story so
actually how did you all why did you all
decide to do that and what explain what
cotech is and why yeah so call tech uh
is a math type setting library so
um it takes math or mathy strings um in
like a latex format
and formats them so that they look nice
on the web right people might not
realize it but like you know if you want
to write like an integral symbol or even
like kind of an x in the note like the
way it looks in like a math textbook
it's a different type of formatting
than
kind of your typical web formatting and
uh you need special rules for like
laying it out and the like spacing
between things and stuff uh and and
there was a way to do it before there
was contact uh it was a tool called
mathjax
and we still use math checks on our
website but for uh
a lot of the use cases that we had which
were like
math that changed a lot or like
taking uh when you like go to the next
problem on an exercise having a whole
bunch of new math put on the page
mathjax was just too slow um so we uh
over the course of a couple weeks ben
alkart and i uh threw together a sort of
a small prototype of something that
would
do the same thing that mathjax did for a
small subset of the math that we used um
but a lot faster like a lot faster how
much faster uh so the original
originally was like 100 times faster
um
and uh now it's still faster i guess we
haven't done any benchmarks recently but
and that's a big deal i mean this is
something y'all then contributed it to
the larger i mean hopefully this is
something that most everyone could use
actually we've uh i've been sort of
following um projects and stuff and
there's there's definitely new projects
that need math type setting uh context
is now one of the one of the things they
look into and there's
many different i don't know websites and
stuff that now use contact as their sort
of default implementation that must feel
pretty good that was what a two-week
initial
foray into it yeah it's actually uh but
it's but it's
over over time i've put in a lot more
time and uh i've learned a lot of how
tech works and stuff which has been
interesting but tech like the not the
tech industry like no sorry
the formatting yeah the formatting
language language all right and what is
you know for people who aren't software
engineers or software developers what is
your day-to-day like
um
day-to-day is pretty nice coming to work
late
um well not that late but uh and uh
later than me
and uh just sort of i don't know settle
down
uh catch up on email
and stuff and then um
tackle whatever problem trying to solve
so like right now i'm working on
figuring out how to
take some of the like labels in our
images in our exercises
and figure out how to take those strings
send them to translators so they can be
translated and then take the translated
strings and put them back into our
images and so
some you know writing code to try to do
that a lot of testing things out
a lot of code wow i didn't even realize
so it's actually to take the the text
from an image us so we uh or it's
represented as kind of text behind the
scenes yes and but once it's super
important because if our mission is a
free world-class education for
anyone anywhere
the text should not be in english for
a lot of the world and uh and we we've
had
methods of sort of doing this in the
past um but it was sort of clunky and it
made it difficult for the translators
to translate the text which is a problem
because if it's difficult for the
translators then it doesn't happen as
much and then
it doesn't look as good and stuff so um
trying to sort of ease the transition
for everybody and make it easier to
get our content translated which is good
and you know just to take a step back
you mentioned you interned here twice
um what what brought you to khan academy
i guess as an intern but then eventually
as a full-time engineer um originally
well uh
back to ben albert uh ben alpert was an
intern here before me and i knew him
back from high school and uh sounded
like fun but also um i've been really
interested in education
um and stuff throughout my life i really
like
teaching people things and i worked as
like a
ta in college a bunch and so i
thought about it and thought like you
know a place that does online education
sounds really fun and uh
i um
looked on
the website and
uh i checked out like the con exercises
stuff that we had been going on and saw
that you know people were just writing
really cool problems um for students to
solve and writing uh coming up with
hints to like that we're really good at
explaining exactly how the students
should go through this and i thought
that this was a really cool way to
further education so and since interning
twice and then now being a full-time
engineer what's kind of surprised you
about khan academy
i think the biggest surprise is how
nice the people are i think that
the the sort of the culture that khan
academy creates
with people are very passionate about
the stuff that we do
um we're not we're not in it for the
money or whatever we're here because we
we really care about changing education
and the work that we're doing and so
everyone that ends up here is always
incredibly nice and incredibly
supportive and
you know i have
chats on at the lunchroom you know about
broad ranges of topics but it's always
incredibly fun and people always have
very cool experiences to share
and what are you excited about right now
uh what am i excited about i'm excited
about
sort of
pushing forward i'm excited about trying
to
trying to delve into new things that
people haven't really done before and uh
i know that like
online education has sort of been around
for a while but people have
sort of
they reached a point and sort of
stagnated and and there's a bunch of
like mediocre
online education that's out there um and
i'm excited to see how we can sort of
push forward and design new things and
design exciting things that can help
people learn better well i'm excited
about that too and it's an honor to be
working with you
yep